hello current and welcome to this video
playing Alonso mostly yeah it's got a
very high reading at the moon let me
check that that's what I was highest
right got on 25 at some point yeah okay
has wasted some time here but usually is
lower rated so okay let's go for a
king's indian playing a somewhat off be
lining it with a six and see where that
leads us ya think here well i'll go here
c5 is also a move directly upon
sacrifice there's a famous game box /
off this is also something that black
can go for yeah it's probably a bit
tough him to not go into some kind of
hedgehog i had this before in a game
made the tournament game actually hmm
hmm
okay let's try to keep the tension for a
bit and see what happens maybe I have to
go into into a head shock ultimately hmm
keep going for hmm see going for before
here in this position that's hard to
believe actually that would weaken white
more than it is useful but okay foreign
for some head shock after he takes
Knight takes his rooks are not misplaced
I just keep the tension and see what
what he's doing okay he keeps the
tension as well I came so here this
should be seven looks wrong after t5 but
I'm out of moves a little bit
d5 probably 95 is not so bad getting his
bishop on d3 the bishop is not a great
piece but at least I can trade some
stuff and now the five is a little bit
better as 95 you can move it away but i
think i still play it takes now be fire
VI is probably up for before how to how
to not play that hmm would love to play
be five but it doesn't i took with the e
porn only now really read registered
okay this one may be for Bishop see aid
I put the bishop on d 7 he wants to go
for that pin
stuff like Queenie 494 who makes a rook
look bad on the 8th yeah I don't have
much of experience with this positions
with black and I usually just avoid them
with black because well with wider
attend to win them okay maybe I can do
this 94 I can still take then trying to
go for Queen f8 and age 6 so maybe I can
get that in he had Queen f4 that wasn't
interesting move I can take it as the
queen is attacked okay so f 6 now I
don't think this is so bad I really
feared that the position was far worse
and I get in Bishop f5 next and then I
can take any form and just just get rid
of that bloody bishop the bishop is just
such an awful piece on see aid
well it's okay this position is quite
okay for me don't think what is
something I'm substantial
I think allowing me Queen f8 was a
mistake on his part I mean if I'd still
comfortably I don't get me wrong but I
think the position was already very very
critical interesting choice
just go back try to take next
check those trades help yeah I didn't
think about that move but it's a good
one of course hmm
well and what to do no I cannot I can't
take actually because of the back wing I
just got a five then
I shoot how to do this time morning okay
5sr is a big problem okay i gue 95 I
guess king of fame maybe 94 as well what
I 595 might still be playable somehow
might
if I get an f5 and now it would also
probably be okay I think he has to go I
five himself even though it allows 95
however think you should still do that i
will know sorry after g5 I'm burning ass
bishop and without stupid is sad this is
why it's not playing at five bit slow
him you know yeah I have to do
what what is he doing to me in this game
thats it's not that's not yeah Wow you
can also just move the bishop I mean
probably taking all the seven wins but
if you move the bishop is just winning
strategically I can just take 95 mm and
wins okay okay check bra offered you're
forming a draw here don't want to draw a
third white forfeits on time I know it
was so slow I mean I and yeah can you do
I was a disaster of a game he took took
far too too too long at the end so I
thought well let's offer draw
check okay well now that that opening
wasn't good somehow I mean maybe this is
kind of okay but I have to have to
improve around here I mean why this
better but it shouldn't be shouldn't be
that terrible this is probably not not
good already I don't know here yeah
bishops eh I mean it's wrong on b7 but
this is just a very awkward move until
Queenie seven years to a queen a point
is much better yeah that's also
confirmed by the engine after Queen FYI
i'm basically busted have to go h6 now
now the night if forth wretches is
decisive yeah here I'm somehow playing
jacks digs this would be six yeah maybe
I have to take maybe I have to take it
at some I saw that line of course but
he's got five yeah g5 Queenie to then I
don't know what is he doing here a queen
FYI can go to reform yeah he back at
five and it's my looks terrible I just
completely outplayed me here check okay
and I was Howard's don't know what to do
with social situations where they are so
terribly slow but have outplayed me
should I just resign sometimes I do that
but yeah
but you know so it also feels wrong for
me to just reason I native day if they I
mean I always think that coffin you draw
is some kind of compromise there I don't
know I don't know how you how you see
that in an incremental control he will
certainly won that game but it was also
entirely unnecessary for him to come
into that situation when I was
completely outplayed here he was like 20
seconds up on the clock and took a long
time for four simple decisions yeah I
don't know what do you think thanks for
watching